welcome back to las vegas now subaru
fans this is the moment you have all
been waiting for we stopped by subaru of
las vegas the sponsors of this next
segment to learn more about their
all-new electric vehicle and of course
how they're helping the community give
back
[Music]
i'm burton hughes general manager of
subaru of las vegas and i am so excited
about our all all-electric ev that is
being released called the subaru sultera
the great thing about the new solterra
is it is truly designed to be an
off-road all-wheel drive vehicle in the
subaru fashion it is got 8.3 inches of
ground clearance and i have actually
seen the vehicle in testing off-road and
it's amazing it has x mode which you can
dial in the extreme mud the dirt the
snow you can put those settings in it
has a
hill descent control kill ascent control
it's designed very aerodynamically and
it's really designed to go off-road it's
just an amazing all-wheel drive vehicle
so people that want to go off-road may
not think that you can do it in an eevee
and all electric but you can and the the
sol terra does have 220 miles of range
with that battery pack fully charged
and with that all-wheel drive system it
is something that you can take off-road
and enjoy the day and and have a good
time and the all-wheel drive with
electricity
powering it it's got an amazing torque
it's just it's really really good
off-road
go on to subaru.com
take a look at the solterra online the
order bank is now open you can select
color and options get in now though
because there's a limited supply for the
2023 model run so our march events are
still being worked out but let me tell
you what we've been doing in the month
of february we have spent 14 days of
love going out to our seniors working
with helping hands of vegas valley we've
been repairing appliances and just
taking care of our seniors and loving on
them we've also been partnering with the
ronald mcdonald house and cooking up a
valentine's meal for families on
valentine's day and partnering with the
partnership for nevada homeless youth
we've been working with them and and and
getting them clothes and food and socks
and all that fun stuff and we do have
something really special going right now
and that is a food drive that is helping
the rescue mission and that goes to the
end of the month
thank you subaru las vegas for
sponsoring this segment give them a call
at 702-495-2100
or just visit subaru of lasvegas.com
they do have a special offer going on
right now 1.9 financing for
well-qualified buyers for up to 48
months on select 2022 models we'll be
right back